today governor steve sisilak unveiled a
new state program for parents of
children children with disabilities it
makes five million dollars in federal
grants available families could get
thousands of dollars they really need
hector mejia live this afternoon in
henderson where the governor made the
announcement hi hector
hey these are five thousand dollar
grants designed to help families cover
expenses related to education housing
transportation and assisted technology
the governor's office says nevada is
first in the entire country to roll out
something like this
it's called the transforming
opportunities for toddlers and students
grant program five million dollars in
initial federal funds governor steve
sisilak said this is the first statewide
grant program being launched with
american rescue plan funding it was
approved by the state legislature
families who qualify for the 5 thousand
dollar grants do not have to pay it back
due to school closures and the
transition to distance learning many
students in special education programs
lost access to vital programs and
services to which they were entitled the
governor made the announcement at the
nevada blind children's foundation where
we met mother ramona lowe and her 16
year old son christian who is blind
virtual learning was challenging because
i didn't know like how i was going to do
my classes and
the navigation with
the speech that i was using christian is
a junior right now in high school he's
going to be a senior next year
and i
had a problem with them not being able
to supply him with a braille
high school diploma in a braille year
but
that's his language and we need to learn
to speak in their language
and having finances and resources is
essential the state expects up to one
thousand people to be eligible right now
and immediately after that announcement
families here were invited to apply on
the spot we're actually posting a link
where you can apply and check out the
eligibility requirements you can head
over to eight newsnow dot com reporting
in henderson hector mejia live local now